hey guys i'm back in toronto i had to
come home in a bit of a rush most of
this video is from about a month ago
when i caught the delta variant of covid
in moscow i wanted to make this into a
video because i've been vocal about how
covet has been handled and how i've been
against lockdowns and vaccination
passports etc as a lot of my audience is
disagreeable and skeptical like me i
thought they should know what my
experience of covid was like
keep in mind this is the second time
i've had it
overall it was quite unpleasant
significantly worse than the first time
around i was unbelievably weak i had a
wheeze for about 10 days a cough for a
few days brain fog anxiety my skin broke
out but mainly serious muscle fatigue
and weakness if i wasn't a healthy
person i'd actually be worried about how
bad that could have been for me
i will be waiting to get the vaccine
until there's a bit more evidence that
it's safe and we'll see how i feel in
six months but the experience was
definitely unpleasant enough this time
that i would consider getting the
vaccine like i've said before i'm not
anti-vaxx i'm just skeptical of new
medical procedures and my overly
sensitive immune system's response to
said new medical procedures
i'll probably consider getting it in
four to six months or so when my current
immunity wears off and more time is
passed to judge potential side effects
of the vaccine however i can tell you
the side effects of this new variant of
kovid
were unpleasant so here's my experience
it's a bit disorganized because i was
super brain foggy the whole time i'm
better now i'm just mainly
tired but life is a little bit tiresome
sometimes so
i hope you enjoy
thought i might as well film this
turns out i have covid
second time which is where the
government isn't lying about everything
did you have covet again huh is
different than last time
uh andre has it he got tested at a
russian clinic and the doctor basically
said the second time around because you
have some immunity
it's less bad so she said it's about
four days
i
had a serious achy body today yesterday
i was sick too
i had a fever i sounded like a zombie
about two hours ago my nose has just
been like running
water
uh i've i've probably sneezed 40 times
today so
i'm not
going outside to infect other people
although the entirety of russia
obviously has it shocker
and
well i don't know hopefully this only
lasts four days i did sound bad enough i
did two podcasts this week i sounded bad
enough a couple of hours ago that i
cancelled the next ones
so
hopefully i can sleep but
i don't know i wouldn't have got tested
andre actually went to the doctor for
something else and they were like do you
want a cover test
so
we will see how long this lasts this is
day two this is what i sound like
it occurred to me this morning that
about two weeks ago scarlett had
a cough and a fever
fever for a few days and a cough for
about five days a pretty
like a
long
cough
and
so that's probably where this came from
this is definitely worse than the first
round of covet i had in serbia last year
it turns out moscow's being overtaken by
the delta variant
so the variant thing that we're being
told by the media is definitely true
i feel better today i sound much worse
but i feel better today than i did
yesterday
i had a fever all day yesterday and i
don't have a fever anymore
although i seem to have some lung action
going on
i would say
i wanted to make this video because
um i've been fairly vocal about covet
etc
about what we're being told that's real
what isn't real
and this delta variant is definitely a
little bit i would be concerned if i
wasn't
fairly healthy like if uh when i was on
immune suppressants i used to get
bronchitis every year
and it was terrible
and so if my immune system was
compromised in any way or i was an older
person i'd probably be a bit concerned
about the delta variant
i don't think it's going to last very
long the doctor
told us that because we had coven and we
have some immunity
similar to being vaccinated
that when you get the delta variant or
you get it again it only lasts about
four days
scarlet had symptoms for longer than
four days so i don't know if that's true
but
yeah we'll see i'm not
stuck in bed yesterday i was really achy
really uncomfortable i'm actually
feeling better today but it's gotten
like my skin's breaking out that
happened last time my wrist is sore i
always get
arthritis whenever i get some sort of
virus
and
my nose has just been like
leaking water basically i've been
sneezing i would like to say this one is
unpleasant enough that
yesterday i was like dude this if i had
known this was gonna come maybe i would
have looked at the vaccine
i hadn't been looking at the vaccine
because i already had coven was like why
would i
why would i get it if i already had
coven
there's evidence that having two
vaccines can reduce the likelihood that
you're going to get this delta or reduce
the severity of the disease i would be
concerned like i said if i was an older
person or somebody who wasn't in
really good health
to to get this
i know there haven't been studies done
on mrna vaccines for very long
but this is unpleasant that being said
there's also evidence that prior
infection reduces the severity of delta
because you have some
immunity
built up so
hopefully this is only four days because
this is a pain just to give an example
of this being serious
you see
it's really not great and i'm healthy
looks like i coughed all the mucus away
and now i sound more like a normal
person
i don't mean to be fear-mongering i'm
gonna be fine scarlet's fine andre's
over it already it's just me
but
people who aren't healthy should get
healthy because
it's fairly serious so get healthy
probably get vaccinated if you're not
going to get healthy
or it's going to suck coping day five
i put makeup on put contacts in
feeling more alive my nose is just a
little bit stuffy
[Music]
and i'm at 90
normal again so hopefully in a few days
i'll have a negative test so i recorded
a podcast today
i was
extremely exhausted all day
like weak exhausted
i have a cough that goes off and on in
my lungs i'm going to wee's right now
but i certainly did earlier and i'm
mostly i'm just exhausted also i have no
taste
no taste
i can't taste i mean i only eat like two
things so
it's it's not that much of a loss really
but i can taste salt if there's a lot of
it and i've been eating honey i can eat
honey now
without having autoimmune symptoms
and it's hard to tell
if this is glue or honey
and to be fair
i'm in russia so it really could be glue
sorry
any russian watching this that's a joke
it's a joke at your expense
no i can taste honey a tiny bit but it's
amazing how much taste i've lost so
hopefully that comes back but
there's this piece of hair doing
but if it doesn't
i only like three things anyway so who
cares right [ __ ] it at this point day
eight
of coped
i just did another podcast
i'm exhausted
mainly
yeah
my nose still kind of burns it's where
this covet has like burning my eye was
burning today like my nate the
nasal passages or whatever they're up
here
i felt like my eye was burning if i do
that it hurts a bit of a cough
and
this is like day eight so i hope this
doesn't last forever because it's
getting pretty boring i'm really
exhausted physically weak and tired it's
gonna be two weeks tomorrow that i still
have coping this is stretching out i was
wheezing yesterday i'm still coughing my
nose is still stuffy i'm gonna get
tested in two days to see if it's
i'm negative at least but this is a huge
pain i've been physically exhausted
it sucks and i'm healthy and it still
sucks so
i'm covered negative
see this
that is an instant covered test
stuck very far up both my nostrils
put on to here
no covet
my nose is still a bit stuffy i'd like a
bit of mucus in my lungs but
apparently i have no covet anymore
and i'm going home
and i don't have to do the hotel
quarantine because
i had a positive cova test in the last
14 to 90 days
so something that makes sense shocking
overall
i would not recommend the delta variant
of copid it sucked it really did suck i
was so unbelievably weak muscle-wise for
like a solid 10 days it was crazy i was
walking half a block i was like
oh
and about i think i recorded it a few
days ago i was like if this keeps up i'm
going to the doctor i don't know what
they're gonna do
but this sucks and then two days later
it just turned off i feel
95 back to normal now
so that was
how many days realistically
oh
was that really only a week was that
only eight days
was it 15 days
it was definitely 15 days yeah
okay so it lasted a while 15 days 14 13
i would say 13 days of bad symptoms
but now i'm immune
but it sucked
it really did suck so
if the vaccine does not make anybody
grow third arms or become infertile
it's something to probably consider
i will most likely be considering it
once there's a little bit more evidence
and i'm a little bit more comfortable
with it
as much fun as new vaccines are
i'm a skeptical human being but
if things look good in six months or a
year so i'll probably consider getting
it if covet is still a problem because
that really was pretty nasty
so i hope you enjoyed my covet delta
variant movie
experience
talk to you guys soon